好 到底下個禮拜如何布局
因為今天盤面上有出現一些
好像傳產上來接棒
這樣的變化
從籌碼上來看呢
到底是不是能夠延續
就要來請教我們小哥啦
因為今天的狀況是
已經反彈過了
但是有一點指數的壓力
但是航運股來了
這個剛剛我們在看資料的時候說
怎麼熟悉的味道要回來了
禮拜五在追運
很像21年的感覺
對 在追運這樣
接體肩市場模組
CBO其實漲跌戶線
竹力到底在不在
今天要教大家
好久沒講這個了
為什麼要用抑價
就是比原本的轉換價
還要貴去買可轉載
到底原因是什麼
對啊 今天可以來複習一下
最近的新聞都走這個
復古風
好復古喔
馬士基
SCFI
馬醫生
這個深彩色指路
各位看一下
8月10號上調全年彩色31%
一周飆涨25%
這就是航運
航運你看
最重要的原因是因為
SCFI的運價指數
4月一路走高
來到3500點
在過往疫情的時候
疫情過的那一年不是
集裝鄉運價指數大漲嗎
那時候最高漲到5000點
5000點
現在3500點
其實也漲滿多了
漲滿多了
貨櫃海運業再現疫情農景
所以現在這些像是考古提一樣
是 考古提 對
美濃縣運價衝上1萬美元
你看這個考古提跟以前很像
這個衝逐升溫以前沒有
不過這種紅海航道持續受阻
同航受限 港口擁設
這都是航運股上漲的關鍵字
巴拿馬運河
現在還有萊英和
對 那你看
最懂行為的男人
袁裕財 又來了
袁董又出現了
我們聽了很久的潘董
現在是袁董了
對 相信袁董年底就懂
還有很多首富之爭
回來再袁董了
對 袁董說
地緣政治 尊典率下降 傳奇演誤
這些海運景氣渴望延續到10月
他最懂海運的
是 最懂海運的男人
對 所以這看起來
海運沒什麼問題
從新聞看起來沒問題
我們就要來驗證一下
看籌碼到底怎麼樣
哇
這籌碼好到不得了啊
各位看一下
首先來看長榮
這收完價250塊
251塊 漲跌2%也還好
關聯線33% 算滿溫吞的
對 電子的話這沒什麼
但是以傳產來說
哎呦 居然有關聯線33%呢
對 可是你知道航運類股
飆漲那個年
這33%根本不算
那時候都漲1-200%以上了
各位看到主時
主時各位 乘幾何時
你有看過主時40的
這個有人在問
主力10天5天的數碼集中度怎麼看
小哥有說10以上就不錯了
0到10就小買了
10到20都買
20以上就大買
就是大大買
這40很難得
其實這個指數
通常來到40 50都算是很頂的
暴買
暴買 住了要43
外資連買6天
所以代表說航運內股的籌碼
非常的好
首先來看長榮
你看
這是開步領延上軌
我們有說這種線型是最強的
漲不停比漲停還厲害
你看這現在是漲不停的狀況
漲不停
然後主力連買
外資連買 分點也是連買
所以這是一個籌碼非常漂亮的投信很猶豫對要不要跟啊要不要追大家後面就會追了有投信有買散裝有這個主動型ETF有買
這個後面就會買了
因為你看到後面這樣漲
再不追整個跡下都比人家差
那我們怎麼辦呢
我們怎麼辦
我們是不是又要再當一次航海王
其實我們看一下
他這邊
他從起漲到現在
大概從220到254
其实大概就一根
一根多的涨停满
一成多
对 所以其实我觉得
假如有下跌的时候
你都可以跟上
来看下一个 阳明
阳明也很漂亮
各位看
这边整理这段时间
这个整理非常漂亮
各位你看一下它的带宽
带宽大概六七而已
很窄的带宽
超级窄
非常窄的带宽
一开布林
就是要让你跟上
那像這種呢
即便它有漲停
你都不能空它
因為這種線型都很漂亮的
主力都連買的
主力連買
所以這個陽明這也不錯
不過呢
從開布林到現在
這漲得有點快
漲得有點快
漲得大概30%
所以這個陽明
你假如這邊
這個還沒買的
你還是等拉回來
這是最強的
今年新刀萬海
六天暴漲逾四成
最強就它
所以看起來買長龍
好像稍微安全一點
船比較大隻
那主頭外資各位看
主力也買 外資也買
分點也是連買
也是開不移連續上漲
這很漂亮
那這種可惜的是
怎樣
它那個沒有那個
最近還沒有那種被關的風險
假如它有被關的話
其實蠻不錯的
搞不好會啊
它還沒有嗎
有機會我覺得
再拉下去一定會有機會
再拉下去有機會
那只要之後被關
都是很好買點
只要被關是不是貨櫃航運
關關關越關越大
事情又要來
對 因為這種被關之後
假如同族群又被關
那代表說
這個族群就是未來的主角
通常我們處置股
看到同族群都出現
那最近就要
就要扛這個族群
好
所以萬海這個還不錯
我們就希望他有機會被關
真的是磕在我們台灣
古名裡面的航海王基因在蠢動
然後另外一個當然是記憶體基因
對 記憶體
南亞科也很厲害
南亞科也是在新高的附近
華房電就追得比較慢一些些
那為什麼
因為華房電的籌碼比較差
你看華房電的籌碼長線是往下
南亞科的籌碼最近是往上
就是主力和大戶特別喜歡南亞科
對 南亞科籌碼不錯
任何拉回來
因為這月線往上了
任何拉回來靠近月薪的時候
都是好賣一點
而且南亞科整理完是創高的
所以這個型態是很漂亮的
在電子股裡面
記憶體最先拉回最先創高
所以我覺得記憶體後面還有行情
後面還有行情
那紅店因為籌碼差的關係
這比較累一點
所以這兩個選擇
我也比較喜歡選南亞科
還是選南亞科
現在市場投票都是投到南亞科
投南亞科
因為從籌碼看起來就這樣
這種籌碼不好
可是最近有漲 這種都是根漲
我們要買這個林漲
不要買這種根漲
因為根漲很容易有個風吹草動
它一下就跌下來了
除非它籌碼變好
對 除非籌碼變好
目前籌碼沒有變好的現象
好 現在看這個
通常是記憶體魔術場
剛剛中大膽有講到威剛
至少植地率來看很甜
但是你看它這個形態是走的
扁平狀在地上
扁平狀 各位
你看一下
近世紀
77塊 最近這30幾塊這看起來我覺得今年破百應該是沒啥問題EPS這個EPS破百沒啥問題那現在你看一下它的股價這四百多塊
這是有點委屈
有點委屈
可是委屈歸委屈
到底籌碼怎麼樣
籌碼最近有稍微慢慢的起來的感覺
慢慢的起來
所以我覺得威剛看起來蠻不錯的
加油威剛
加油
好
來
現在看大力光
大力光就大力了
大力沒問題啦
大力光之前我們有說
那個有個關鍵分點
買在兩三千的時候大買
三多哥嗎
三多哥 對
照顧好記性
三多哥
因為你一直說他籌碼很好
他真的展現出籌碼好的樣子
那三多哥
最近真的爆賺了
那三多哥呢
在高檔還把一些
這個股票賣掉
轉去買什麼你知道嗎
川湖
三多哥實在太省了
有錢人的快樂就是那麼樸實無法
賣5千的買8千買1萬
賣8千那時候跌到6千多
這次該不會踢到鐵板
1萬多
沒有 1萬多
這三多哥下次買什麼
我一定要好跟一下
那這三多哥這樣買完
大力光我們之前講
大力光CBO裡面最漂亮的
本益比最低
8月以來漲不逾4成
好猛
智傑7月每股一億13.94元
這非常強
那最近籌碼也變好了
這個籌碼也不太好
最近籌碼變成連買
那這個投信最近也一直在買
所以我覺得這個大力光很漂亮
8月14號就特別在講過大力光
一直延續講投信不離不棄
繼續不離不棄
真的是
還不錯
你看好像最近又漲上去了
好 接下來看這個華星光
那華星光各位看
華星光在處置的時候
儲置的時候我們最喜歡買
你看它前陣子漲到淨儲置
在前陣子是跌到淨儲置
後面也漲到淨儲置
那漲到淨儲置這邊
各位 這個位置
這邊有出現一個浪子回頭好買點
我們有說淨儲置的下跌
是讓你買的
然後上升的月線
結果這個你看
後面又彈上來
下跌讓你買 後面彈上來
所以這個華星光
它這個示範的
處置的好買點
所以下次有類似股票
這樣的點也是讓你買的
好 再來看這個可轉載
可轉載高一價
這我們有陣子沒講了
對
那高一價最近
這個標的蠻多的
好 變多了
那我們高一價是個好的買點
那我們再加上主力籌碼的過濾
主力籌碼再過濾一下
我們就可以找到更好的買點
是
那高一價什麼意思呢
高價就是說
他CP的微買是大於市值
10塊以上
對 10塊以上
那我們來看一下
像這個第一個智上
記憶體通路的智上
對 那智上各位看
他這個回底的時候
主力並沒有大賣
所以他籌碼是不錯的
他也是算高值利率股
對 高值利率有到4%
那各位看一下他的溢價
他CP微買現在到113
對
市值在103
所以這邊大概多了10塊
那位階也不錯
所以這檔我覺得後面有機會
通常這種溢價就是指
他的現股有機會對不對
對現股有機會
因為這種你買現股是買在103的位置
就轉換之後是103位置
像這種我們都比較建議你去買現股
好 這樣我們看下一檔
下一檔是177的長新
那長新最近的籌碼也不錯
這個主利益買上來之後
這邊並沒有掉下來
然後長新呢 各位看一下
藏心的可轉載的抑價
這抑得太誇張吧抑得有點多啊對啊 怎麼了這來到132買科轉在想什麼想什麼在132
然後他市值才93而已
市值才93
然後科轉再買132
他可能覺得
藏心後面很有機會
所以才用這麼高的
這個微買去買他
這都沒有別的問題
他要花那麼多的溢價
不知道
因為通常看到這麼大的溢價
那籌碼又不錯的
後面長長都會長上去
好 這個是長新的部分
也是特化
接下來看這個3617的碩天
UPS 這個我實在看不懂
但它實在很厲害
一路上去
那最近的籌碼也蠻漂亮的
阻力也是連買
籌碼漂亮
那我們來看殖利率也不錯
有到快4%
那我們就看一下
這個
它的這個CB的微買狀況
那碩天山的微滿狀況
期比來到119
市值來到93
其實也不錯啦
也超過蠻多的
對啊 也超過蠻多的
這個超過大概20幾
那這個型態看起來蠻漂亮的
看起來有點像底部的起漲的狀況
所以這碩天的各位也可以留意一下
因為它前面其實有一個高
對不對 雖然最近感覺上強
是因為它已經提早可能先落底了
而且這個算是懂得發債的
各位看一下
从高档跌下来之后才发债
低档发债
中低档发债
对 算低档发债的
算是利害发债的
有低档发债
有殖利率
有这个高溢价
我觉得科转在三大上涨的要助
他都有了
所以各位呢
这边你可以特别留意现股的部分
好 其实最近有很多募资的公司
都被先打下来
但是募完资之后科转在发行
我們又多了一個可以觀察的商品
其實是很不錯的
對 我們做股票就是理由要多一點
來了
最後一個看世衛行
曾經是腰股
腰股
前陣子也是整理的非常久
最近跟著航運走上來
各位看這籌碼也不錯
這邊是連兩根漲停
隔衝跑掉
今天又進來了
所以這符合這種腰股的節奏
因為之前哥有教過我們
他是很罕見
隔日沖連沖七天
是 很厲害
七天漲停辦
對 沒錯
四維航算是以前非常標的
各位看一下
CBUM在113
市值在96
市值在96代表說
再拉一下一定過轉換價
所以這一檔我覺得拉起來
換的機會蠻高的
有心人
又回到了四維航的身上
所以這個骨子裡面的
航海黃金大家可以考慮一下
至少籌碼真的很好
今天非常謝謝小哥 謝謝
看籌碼真的很有趣
尤其是我們看到航海王
我們重新在星期五
再看到上海集裝箱指數等等的
過去的回憶又開始敲打我們了
但萬萬沒有想到的是
籌碼真的好到爆炸
不過這個很見仁見智
我們常常講
傳染在漲 AI又好厲害
那這邊的話
也許你做一個分散的配置
因為畢竟這一塊呢
目前籌碼非常的好
要緊盯一下運價跟籌碼的狀況
能不能连续的往上拉
那刚刚也讲到了
例如像记忆体CPU里面
像CPU大力光的领军
是真的领军一段时间了
而其他的有一些筹码好
今天还教您可转债的高益价
代表之后对它的股价有所期待
希望大家学起来
好 今天星期五的晚上
非常谢谢三位来宾来到现场
本周是一个压回的状态
但是有发现吗
来宾们观测的指标反而多了
好的股票叠下来
反而觉得敢买的念头上升了
那也希望今天理财答案秀
对你的投资有帮助哦
下周再会了
拜拜